they all day you've been bombarded with
images of what has taken place in
washington too little time has been
spent thinking about why
anyone is trying to understand the
significance of what's going on right
now ought to watch the video
of the woman who was shot inside the u.s
capitol this afternoon
in the footage which we're not going to
show you because it's too upsetting
which you can find on the internet
the woman is standing in a hallway right
off the house floor at the center of the
capitol building
she appears to be in her 20s she's got
an american flag tied around her neck
the scene around her is chaotic people
are bumping into each other yelling
trying to get through the door
into the senate chamber suddenly with no
warning there is gunfire you hear a shot
and the woman falls she's been hit with
a bullet seems like the neck
could be the chest apparently was fired
by someone in law enforcement
people in the hallway scream the camera
closes in on the woman's face
she looks stunned she is staring
straight ahead unblinking
in her eyes you can see that she knows
she's about to die
which in the end she did the woman died
a couple of hours ago at a local
hospital
so what can we learn from this it's not
enough to call it a tragedy
imagine for a second getting the call
and learning that was your daughter
the last time you spoke to her she was
heading to washington for a political
rally
now she's dead you'll never talk to her
again
seriously imagine that if you have
children it will
put you in the right frame of mind
that's what we're watching
and we may be watching a lot more of it
in the coming days
political violence begets political
violence that is always true it is an
iron law it never changes
and we have to be against that no matter
who commits the violence or under what
pretext
no matter how many self-interested
demagogues assure us the violence is
justified
or necessary as they have been assuring
us lying to us
for the past six months we have a duty
to oppose
all of this not simply because political
violence kills other people's children
which it does but because in the end it
doesn't work
no good person will live a happier life
because that girl was killed in the
hallway of the capitol today
so our only option as a practical matter
is to fix what is causing this in the
first place we don't have a choice
you may have nothing in common with the
people on the other side of the country
increasingly you probably don't
but you're stuck with them the idea that
groups of americans will somehow break
off into separate peaceful
nations of like-minded citizens that's a
fantasy
that will not happen there is no such
thing as a
peaceful separation there never has been
and there won't be
the two hemispheres of this country are
inseparably intertwined
they're co-joined twins neither can
leave without killing the other
so that's the first thing to know as
horrifying as this moment
is we have no option but to make it
better to gut it out
the second thing to consider and it's
related to the first is
why the woman who was killed today went
to the rally in the first place
we don't know anything about her but she
did not look particularly radical
she bore no resemblance to the angry
children we have seen again and again
wrecking our cities pasty entitled
nihilist dressed in black setting fire
spray-painting slogans on statues
she didn't look like that the woman in
the capitol hallway looked pretty much
like everyone else
so why was she there on a wednesday
why were any of them there today we
ought to think about that
if you want to fix it you have to think
about that
the only reason this country is rich and
successful
is because for hundreds of years we have
enjoyed a stable political system and
the only reason that system is stable
is because it's a democracy it responds
to voters
democracy is our pressure relief valve
as long as people sincerely believe they
can change things by voting
they stay calm they don't storm the
bastille they don't burst into the house
chamber
they talk and they organize and they
vote
but the opposite is also true if people
begin to believe that their democracy is
fraudulent
if they conclude that voting is a
charade the system is
rigged and it's run in secret by a small
group of powerful dishonest people who
are acting in their own interests
then god knows what could happen
actually we do know
what could happen it's happening right
now
it's happened in countless other
countries over countless centuries and
the cycle is
always the same because human nature
never changes listen to us screams the
population
shut up and do what you're told replied
their leaders in the face of dissent the
first
instinct of illegitimate leadership is
to crack down
on the population but crackdowns never
make it better
instead they always make the country
more volatile and more dangerous
the people in charge really understand
that they don't want to they don't care
to learn or listen because
all this conversation is a referendum on
them and their leadership
so they clamp down harder obey i tell
you obey
this is the romanov program it ends
badly
every single time but that doesn't mean
they won't try it again
of course they will because it's their
nature it's how we got here in the first
place
millions of americans sincerely believe
the last election
was fake you can dismiss them as crazy
you can call them conspiracy theorists
you can kick them off twitter
but that won't change their minds rather
than trying to change their minds
to convince them and reassure them that
the system is real that the democracy
work
as you would do if you cared about the
country or the people who live here
our new leaders will try to silence them
what happened today will be used by the
people taking power to justify stripping
you of the rights you were born with as
an american
your right to speak without being
censored your right to assemble
to not be spied upon to make a living to
defend your family most critically
these are the most basic and ancient
freedoms that we have
they're why we live here in the first
place they're why we're proud to be
americans they're what make us different
and they're all now in peril
when thousands of your countrymen storm
the capitol building
you don't have to like it we don't you
can be horrified by the violence and as
we said and we'll say it again we are
horrified
it's wrong but if you don't bother to
pause
and learn a single thing from it
from your citizens storming your capitol
building then you're a fool
you lack wisdom and you lack
self-awareness you have no place running
a country
we got to this sad chaotic day for a
reason
it is not your fault it is their fault